well if there's someone who knows about
a bad breakup it's Miss Independent
Kelly Clarkson and she's unpacking the
pain of her divorce from Brandon
Blackstock with two fires new breakup
Anthem and I can't believe I stayed as
long as I stay divorce is really one day
the lyrics in mind follow the breakdown
of a relationship which has her guessing
and in her other song me Kelly hints at
Deception you're insecurity was the
death of you and me
you're the one with secret
the singles are just a taste of what's
to come from Kelly's tent studio album
chemistry out June 23rd Kelly says the
14 tracks will trace the quote many
stages of grief and loss and they cross
the line and steal your shine there's a
lot of questions that I just have to
answer before releasing it like I don't
know how anybody I'll just be real with
you goes through
grief like divorce without having an
outlet I have you to think yeah
foreign